remember that now legendary meeting in
the Oval Office between Donald Trump and
Russia officials the day after Donald
Trump fired James Comey during which
Donald Trump spilled classified secrets
to the Russians more details have now
surfaced about that meeting over the
weekend and it is an absolute and total
abomination according to a document
summarizing the meeting Donald Trump
straight-up
admitted to the Russians that firing FBI
director James Comey the day before
relieved quote great pressure on him
related to the Russia investigation and
also referred to James Comey as a nutjob
take a look at this quote from Donald
Trump
on may 10th 2017 during that Oval Office
Russian meeting as per a document read
to the New York Times by a US officials
by a US official I just fired the head
of the FBI he was crazy a real nutjob I
faced great pressure because of Russia
that's taken off later saying I'm not
under investigation
I know I know the committed trumpet will
say David that's fake news it's
speculation it's not true it's based on
what one US official read to the New
York Times over the phone but just like
with the first reports from this meeting
Sean Spicer the White House press
secretary is not disputing the account
of the meeting including these comments
he merely defended the firing of James
Comey do you realize that Donald Trump
has been more upfront with the Russians
in terms of why he fired James Comey
then he was with the American people and
it seems like he's not even trying to
deny these stories when they come out
whenever the Washington Post of the New
York time has some sources tell them a
transcript of what happened during these
meetings Trump either goes on Twitter
and explains why he did it or Sean
Spicer goes on and defends why Trump
fired Comey rather than say oh no he
would never call him a nutjob because
they are they're admitting to these
things they are doing these things and
interestingly according to legal expert
Jeffrey Toobin this is getting close to
a confession to the crime of obstruction
of justice check out jeff toobin on CNN
well if you just parse
the words that Donald Trump says it does
seem very close to a confession of
obstruction of justice he is talking
about James Comey who was investigating
him and his campaign in connect with the
whole Russia campaign manner and he says
I fired him and the pressures off I mean
I it doesn't seem much more complicated
than that
you know the insults the nutjob crazy
whatever I mean you know people can
judge whether that kind of talk is
appropriate or not but I don't think
it's legally all that significant what's
significant is that he's saying that
there was pressure and he got rid of it
that seems pretty straightforward to me
so then Wolf Blitzer asked the right
question to Jeffrey Toobin about intent
here and Jeffrey Toobin addresses that
as well how does that fit into building
a case for intent well III think the
words speak speak of his intent he he
thought this investigation was a problem
and he got rid of it now apparently the
latest justification is that this was
some kind of four dimensional chess that
he was playing with the Russians and
explain it and this was in designed to
advance the foreign policy interests of
the United States so to be clear the
White House defended these words by
Trump did not dispute them so to me that
means these were the words that were
said and we can analyze them Trump said
he quote faced great pressure because of
Russia that's interesting and it's
interesting because publicly we don't
really know exactly what type of
pressure he was facing because we don't
know what the investigation has turned
up so far and we don't know what the
White House knows about what the
investigation has turned out so far so
that's potentially huge and again the
White House is not disputing any of this
they are defending the firing which
means that contrary to what the White
House originally said was the reason for
the firing of James Comey the real
reason was to cut the Russia
investigation short do you understand
Pat why I'm guessing you get it but do
you understand does anybody understand
the White House is admitting that they
lied about why they fired James Comey
and the real reason may
be the crime of obstruction of justice
and it's just so insulting to the
American people because he's not even
trying to cover his tracks
I mean John Oliver is calling this
stupid Watergate because this is all the
malicious intent that Watergate had all
the potential consequences but everyone
in that office is just so incredibly
stupid they can't even deal with the
Commun competence is what's striking
about it and hey you know what I can
sleep easy at night because at least
Trump didn't use a private email server
or wear a light-colored suit when he was
talking about something really really
serious because that would really be bad
that would be the real scandal that
would be the real scam send me your
thoughts obstruction of justice what do
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
we'll be back after this today's program
made possible in part by taga dabbe the
hosting specialists whatever sort of
hosting solution makes sense for your
website or your business I recommend you
check out CagA dab at signup taga dab
comm slash TDPS this include dedicated
server solutions virtual private server
solutions cloud server solutions and for
those interested in checking out the
cloud server options you can get a
ten-pound
credit at signup tag adapt comm slash
TDPS taga dev is really proud of their
team of expert hosting specialists 70%
of their business comes from repeat
orders and recommendations that they get
from existing customers which is really
a testament to the support that they
give their customers they have a nine
point seven out of 10 rating on
Trustpilot which scores as excellent in
case you were wondering please check out
the 10-pound discount towards cloud
services at signup CagA Deb comm /t VPS
by supporting our sponsors who are also
supporting our show